من المرجح أن يكون هذا الماس
رقماً قياسياً عالمياً لأن كمية اللون الوردي الموجودة
بداخلها نادرة للغاية
[موسيقى]
قبل إنشاء DMCC ،
لم تكن هناك تجارة ألماس في
دبي اليوم تمثل أكثر من 25 مليون
دولار من تجارة الألماس وقد انتهى الأمر
هناك مع أنتويرب كواحد من
مركزي الماس في العالم ، لذا فإن هذا من
أجل rotonda من بورصة دبي للماس
، ربما يكون لدينا ما قيمته من خمسة عشر إلى سبعة عشر
مليار دولار من الماس الخام الذي
يمر عبر هذا
لسلسلة توريد الماس يتميز عمال المناجم
بالتعدين في الغالب في  أفريقيا
يتم استيراد الماس إلى دبي من
خلال مكتب كيمبرلي عندما
يخرج الماس من الأرض ، فغالبًا ما
يكون عليه شحم أو أجزاء من الصخور ،
لذا يجب أن يكون نظيفًا ،
نقوم بعمل أحجام مختلفة وبعد
أن نقوم بتصنيف الأحجام المختلفة
إلى  الصفات المختلفة التي
نصنعها للطرود مع مراعاة كل عميل
ونأخذها إلى أرض العطاء ،
ندعو جميع العملاء للسماح لهم
ألقِ نظرة على سعر الكلمة الذي يقرره
السوق ، هذا شيء لن
تجده في كثير من الأحيان مرة أخرى مزيجًا من
الحجر الكبير مع الكثير من الألوان
والوضوح الاستثنائي ، نرسم جميع
الشقوق الموجودة بالداخل ، ثم
ندع الخوارزمية تحسب  ما هي أعلى
قيمة للأحجار داخل
المرحلة النهائية ، لا يزال التلميع في الغالب
يتم كما هو الحال منذ
مئات السنين
بمجرد تلميع شيء ما بعيدًا ،
لا يمكنك لصقه مرة أخرى ، فهذه هي
النتيجة بعد شهور من العمل الشاق ،
أحجار استثنائية تستحق حقًا  عشرات
الملايين من الدولارات نمت دبي من
صفر تقريبًا إلى ثاني أكبر
مركز دولي لتجارة الماس
وعندما تكون في المركز الثاني ، فإن المكان الوحيد
الذي تريد أن تكون فيه هو رقم واحد